en el vídeo anterior hablamos de los
tres estados de la materia que son mucho
más familiares por nuestra experiencia
día a día es el estado sólido y lo voy a
poner aquí sólido ok el estado líquido
am también lo voy a poner aquí líquido
ok y el gas aquí voy a poner el estado
gaseoso gas ok
sin embargo mencioné que hay un cuarto
estado en el cual no profundicen porque
usualmente no está en el temario de los
primeros cursos de química pero en los
comentarios decir vídeo hubo un poco de
discusión acerca de este cuarto estado
por lo tanto pensé hacer un vídeo
explicando un poco sobre este estado
llamado plasma y lo voy a poner con este
color el cuarto estado es el plasma y
bueno la gente lo considera como el
cuarto estado porque tiene algunas
propiedades de los gases en algunos
casos es casi un subconjunto de los
gases sin embargo también tiene
propiedades de conductividad que
normalmente no asociar jazz con un gas y
para que lo sepas la prima
escuchamos este nombre pensamos que debe
ser una cosa muy exótica el plasma sin
embargo no es tan exótico en el primer
vídeo dije que solo es algo que ocurre a
temperaturas muy altas lo cual no es
100% correcto no tiene que ser a
temperaturas altas realmente debería
haber dicho que bajo ciertas
circunstancias específicas donde tienes
un campo electromagnético muy fuerte o
algo que tiene que suceder para que
choquen los electrones o para que se
desprendan los electrones de los gases
pues de otra manera mantendrían esos
electrones está algo parecido a lo que
sucede en el metal
cuando hablamos sobre los enlaces
metálicos hablamos sobre la noción de un
mar de electrones por ejemplo aquí si
hablamos del hierro y déjame dibujarlo
aquí para que lo entiendas mejor
imagínate que aquí tengo el hierro
ok tengo aquí dos átomos de hierro
déjame ponerlo así
ok efe y bueno lo que pasa en los
metales es que tienen tantos electrones
que están dispuestos a dar los los
electrones solo flotan a afuera de todos
estos átomos justo algo así creando un
mar de electrones van a crear un mar de
electrones más o menos así o bueno una
especie de mar de electrones entonces
los átomos se convierten en una carga
positiva de iones ok estos van a tener
una carga positiva porque han donado un
montón de electrones a este más de
electrones por lo tanto son atraídos por
el mar y esto es lo que hace que los
metales sean muy maleables y aún más
importante lo que les permite conducir
electricidad pero todos ellos están
realmente muy juntos y esto los hace una
estructura muy densa el plasma es una
situación donde si tomas gases y
recuerda que los gases son cosas
bastantes distantes déjame ponerlo así
por ejemplo aquí podría tener un átomo
de gas por ejemplo aquí otro átomo de
gas este para más o menos así algo más o
menos así poder tener aquí
y va más o menos así ok son átomos que
están bastante distantes
entonces si tomas un grupo de átomos que
están en un gas bueno pues tiene una
energía cinética muy alta aunque no es
necesario ya que podría suceder a
presiones muy bajas pero se mueven
alrededor y chocan entre ellos y aunque
no están tan cerca el uno del otro ya no
tiene una estructura fija o bueno no
tienen fricción entre sí como en el caso
de un líquido pero lo que sucede con el
plasma es una situación donde se aplica
un campo electromagnético tan fuerte que
los electrones quieren disociarse y
bueno por eso aquí tengo un buen de
electrones esos que van a estar justo
por aquí tengo un buen de electrones que
comienzan a chocar fuera de los átomos
como sabemos un sólido tiene su propia
forma pero en el caso del plasma el
plasma tomará la forma de su recipiente
como un gas y es que a veces se describe
como un gas ionizado está escrito como
yo iniciado porque los electrones están
cargados y cuando los electrones están
cargados entonces los átomos toman carga
positiva déjame ponerlo así estos átomos
van a tomar una carga
y una carga positiva ok algo así y la
pregunta sería qué es lo que permite eso
esencialmente la conducción de
electricidad porque ahora estos
electrones son libres de moverse podrías
decir que esto suena bastante raro o
inclusive puedes preguntarte dónde
existe eso y bueno es que probablemente
esté más cerca de tu casa de lo que te
imaginas porque este tipo de estado de
la materia se encuentra en los rayos de
una tormenta en los relámpagos y déjame
ponerlo aquí
pago el pago ok y de hecho podría hacer
un vídeo entero hablando de los
relámpagos pero déjenme bajar un poco la
pantalla vamos a bajar un poco la
pantalla porque quiero explicarte un
poco qué es lo que pasa cuando tenemos
un relámpago
imagínate que por aquí tenemos una nube
y déjame ponerlo con este color tengo
por aquí una nube más o menos así sé de
minube ok algo más o menos así y esta
tiene una diferencia de potencial enorme
con el suelo antes de poner aquí el
suelo y debido a esta gran diferencia de
voltaje entre estas dos ya que bueno
esta nube tiene un montón de electrones
que quieren entrar justo aquí al suelo y
dejan poner aquí los electrones aquí
tengo un montón de electrones ok con
carga negativa o que estos electrones lo
que quiera hacer es a entrar aquí al
suelo y el problema es que no pueden
porque el aire es bastante mal conductor
de hecho es un aislante pero lo que pasa
es que tanto potencial eléctrico aquí
que esos electrones que están cerca de
las moléculas del aire justo por aquí
imagínate que esta es una molécula
otra por aquí y como tenemos los
electrones muy cerca de estas moléculas
del aire entonces y bueno al menos como
yo lo veo sus electrones quieren escapar
de estas nubes así que los electrones
empiezan a querer alejarse usando las
moléculas del aire y así lo voy a poner
van a empezar a alejarse y bueno si
estás hablando de que el aire es una
mezcla de oxígeno nitrógeno y dióxido de
carbono y entonces empiezan a irse lejos
de la nube empiezan a irse lejos la nube
los electrones empiezan a disociarse y
empiezan a formar este aire ionizado
esto pasa a tal grado que puedes obtener
una conducción desde la nube hasta el
suelo creando así el relámpago y lo voy
a poner más o menos así y esta
conducción es cuando el aire está en
estado plasma la conducción permite
temperaturas extremadamente altas y los
electrones fluyen todo el camino hasta
llegar al suelo bueno otro ejemplo común
en el que podrías ver el estado plasma
es en las estrellas eso es porque tienes
campos electromagnéticos muy fuertes y
una presión extremadamente alta
resumiendo en este tipo de ambiente
podemos conseguir un estado donde todos
los electrones puedan separarse de las
cosas estas cosas no quieren perder sus
electrones he pensado en hablar sobre
esto porque es un tema muy interesante y
existe en un plano universal y bueno
digo universal porque están en las
estrellas y es que las estrellas están
formadas casi todos de plasma de hecho
es el estado de la materia más común en
el universo el plasma es el estado de la
materia más común en el universo pese a
que nosotros en nuestra vida cotidiana
es muy probable que encontremos sólidos
líquidos y gas es mucho más que el
estado plasma
otra cosa que quiero aclarar y eso fue
en el vídeo pasado déjame bajar la
pantalla de la otra cosa que quiero
hablar o aclarar es que en el último
vídeo hable sobre la unión de las
moléculas del agua vamos a decir que
estamos hablando en el estado sólido y
por aquí tengo a un oxígeno lo voy a
poner justo por aquí y bueno por acá
tengo un hidrógeno ok
este va a ser mi hidrógeno por acá tengo
a otro hidrógeno am lo voy a poner aquí
y bueno aquí tengo un par de electrones
y aquí también tengo un par de
electrones ok y por otro lado aquí tengo
otro hidrógeno ok aunque está pegado a
un oxígeno
supongamos aquí supongamos que aquí
tengo otro oxígeno y bueno voy a suponer
entonces que aquí tengo a mi otro
hidrógeno ok y bueno por aquí hay otros
electrones voy a poner aquí un oxígeno
primero y después aquí otro hidrógeno ya
mí se me ocurre poner por acá otro
hidrógeno y bueno aquí tengo otros dos
pares de electrones y otros dos pares de
electrones y bueno es que hable sobre
este concepto y antes hemos hablado
muchas veces sobre esto
este oxígeno este oxígeno este este
comienza a tener una carga parcial
negativa es decir este oxígeno empieza a
atraer a los electrones porque con el
hidrógeno prácticamente todos los
electrones están moviéndose cerca del
oxígeno lo que da este oxígeno una carga
parcial negativa esto es porque el
oxígeno es mucho más electro negativo
ahora por otra parte el hidrógeno
comienza a tener una carga parcial
positiva lo voy a poner así ok porque
los electrones se están moviendo cerca
del oxígeno y entonces el hidrógeno
termina siendo como ese protón que está
flotando por ahí porque dijimos que la
mayoría de los casos ni siquiera tienen
neutrones así que esto tiene una carga
ligeramente positiva y entonces bueno
pues éste tiene una ligera carga
positiva esto también tiene una ligera
carga positiva y de hecho el extremo
positivo de la molécula de agua es
atraído por el extremo negativo y lo
llame enlaces polares lo cual muestra
que en memoria de química en
preparatoria no es
al realmente debería de haberlo llamado
puentes de hidrógeno y este de aquí este
de aquí es un puente de hidrógeno y es
por eso que no quería confundirte es
sólo cuestión del nombre que utilice
sólo quiero aclarar esto porque como se
le conoce normalmente es como un puente
de hidrógeno así es como se le conoce en
química y bueno no quiero confundirte y
bueno es que este es el enlace que
existe entre un átomo de hidrógeno
parcialmente positivo y un átomo de
oxígeno a hacerlo otra vez por acá a un
átomo de oxígeno que está parcialmente
negativo recuerda que el átomo de
hidrógeno es parcialmente positivo
porque sus electrones están cerca del
oxígeno recuerda que esto va más o menos
así o que más o menos requiere algo sin
y el átomo de oxígeno es parcialmente
negativo porque ha robado todos esos
electrones de el hidrógeno y los puentes
de hidrógeno
tenemos uno por ejemplo más o menos aquí
los puentes de hidrógeno tienden a
formarse entre el hidrógeno
y bueno de hecho entre el hidrógeno y un
grupo de átomos muy electro negativos y
estos son y déjame ponerlo con este
color el nitrógeno el nitrógeno el flúor
el flúor ok y el oxígeno de hecho estos
son los tres átomos más electro
negativos así que cuando el nitrógeno se
une con el hidrógeno a pensemos en nh 3
y lo voy a poner con este color
imagínate que aquí tenemos el troje no
pero aquí se une con un hidrógeno por
aquí se une con otro hidrógeno ok y por
acá se va a unir con otro hidrógeno pasa
exactamente lo mismo están electro
negativo que se da en la misma situación
todos los electrones se mueven cerca del
nitrógeno y entonces por aquí tienes una
carga parcialmente negativa ok y estos
van a tener una carga parcialmente
positiva parcialmente positiva
parcialmente positiva esto en los
extremos del hidrógeno lo mismo pasa con
el fluoruro de hidrógeno
y lo voy a poner por aquí el h
el hf en el cual tienes puentes de
hidrógeno pasa exactamente el mismo en
este caso serían atraídos por parte del
flúor lo que hacen que se formen los
puentes de hidrógeno y bueno solo quería
aclarar eso en fin con esto creo que
podemos regresar algunas las ideas del
último vídeo y de hecho hacer algunos
problemas así que nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo